butt slapping you may think it's weird
but it's something a lot of athletes do
it's a fixture of sports broadcasts
locker rooms and cable comedy shows but
when a middle school swimmer allegedly
slapped a teammate's butt he ended up
facing a nearly 2year sexual misconduct
investigation the teenager says he's
innocent until the AP he and the
teammate who reported him previously
accused each other of bullying after a
falling out his mom says the conflict
between the kids had seemingly been
resolved by their coaches in schools but
safe sport a sports watch that looks
into abuse allegations ended up
investigating the team while their
investigation is ongoing they're already
treating him like a predator he's been
forced to be chaperon that swim meets
knapping his young athletic career of
course allegations of abuse should be
taken seriously but part of that means
conducting timely investigations and
knowing the difference between a middle
school misunderstanding and truly
predatory behavior hey hey come on good
game flat B man hey good game get flat B